luke bell a rising country
singer-songwriter has died one week
after he was reported missing in arizona
he was 32 years old
the tucson police department confirmed
his death noting he was found in midtown
tucson and the investigation is ongoing
luke's cause of death has not been
revealed
for i am the bravest bull fighter that i
ever dared to depend
yes i am the bravest bull fighter that
ever dared depends
news of the musician's death is
receiving an outpour of love from the
country music community joshua headley
tweeted r.i.p to a real one been a long
time since i saw him and i was just
talking about him the other day
wondering what he's been up to
truly a sad night for country music
the band mike in the moon pies shared
how heartbroken they are on instagram
the man and his music left an impression
he was a real deal traveling troubadour
out there on that lost highway do
yourself a favor and put on some luke
bell tunes tonight in his memory
rest in peace friend
and margot price delivered this tribute
rest easy to our dear friend
luke had collaborated with margot along
with alabama shakes and langhorne slim
he even played supporting gigs for
willie nelson in 2014 luke released his
debut album don't mind if i do
and by 2016 luke signed a record deal
and released a self-titled album
luke opened up about his passion for
country music in a 2018 interview with
diddy tv i got more and more into
country music as i did country things i
found a box of records you know and and
found some old country records in that
um
like merle haggard and hank snow and
that kind of stuff
hank williams and
and uh
i just that
living the lifestyle
of
working in the country and then
started listening to country music and
it just made sense
[Applause]
mister in the mirror where's my friend
[Music]
i went out on the town tonight
hey
[Music]
where you hey